foreign
what's up Alex
Hey Brother John how are you partying
dude what about you
hi I think some would call it a party
but I'm lying to you man I'm at work man
I'm at work uh well I'm not really at
work I'm running a scam here called a
podcast but it's cool so what's up with
you man
uh not a whole lot uh well actually no
that's a lie myself uh we've got a lot
going on uh
to the question and see if uh where we
can go from there cool uh I work a uh
normal uh full-time job okay and I'm
also trying to get our small little
business off the ground and in the
process I'm trying to figure out how to
do that get the proper attention to my
wife and two-year-old
and then give enough attention to the
business so that it keeps making
progress keep hammering down on debt
because we're doing that plan as well
and really just not trying to leave
everything behind me just in ashes it
seems like where it's happening so some
yeah something's happened that
precipitated this call what is it
um and man I just feel fried and then I
I I'm trying to like I said I'm trying
to
get the business going the goal is to
make this a full-time gig and what's
your current day job
I'm an engineer okay and what's the
business you're trying to crank up
uh we're actually a small scale farming
that's turned into a larger scale
farming and I find a lot of happy black
and white huh all right no I I can't
imagine how
how what a gift it is to go from being
an engineer and that pressure and that
all the spreadsheets and all of the all
the stuff right and then heading out to
the farm
what kind of farming are you doing
Dave produce we did I think this year we
did somewhere around four acres of
produce okay uh hundreds of meat birds
uh thousands of uh dozens of eggs I
think 2200 dozen eggs is what we can do
a year and uh
I also added honeybees so because why
not why not Yeah well yeah why not
um is that are you making money on that
are you still dumping money into it
actually I am in the uh positive uh it's
not much
um the so I'm trying to use the day job
to
uh you know uh get the big equipment and
stuff like that and uh funded that away
uh when I you know ideally stepped into
it full time that I don't have to keep
uh you know buying equipment and that
way that hopefully the first full-time
year is much more profitable
um so yeah there's a few thousand bucks
being made not much but there's a lot of
also investment in there as well so if I
were to somehow be able to have that you
know burnished to me then it would be
much more impressive but right now it's
it's not very impressive which I didn't
really expect
what just I need to oh go ahead I was
gonna say uh
here's the bottom line is you've got a
lot going on man a lot
and I am all about
all about like right now I'm writing
another book
uh this is my busy season when I'm on
the road all over the place last week I
was in three states okay
um I got this show co-host the Ramsey
show I've got other media that I mean
it's it's Madness and three weeks ago I
sat down with my wife and we mapped out
in the next three months they're gonna
be wild
maybe the next four months it's gonna be
Madness I canceled some family plans
sent an email out to all of my family
and said we're not hosting holidays this
year it's just not it's going to be too
maddening
um so what I tell you that to tell you
man sometimes with work and with little
kids which I got two
um
and being married trying to hold that
all together there's seasons of chaos
and that's completely okay
it's when everybody knows this chaos is
coming this chaos is here here's how
we're gonna navigate it we're all on the
same page we're checking in my wife and
I check in once a week if not twice a
week where are we where are we where are
we
and it's got an end date to it
and it sounds like I'm just gonna be
honest with you how old are you
just turned 30. okay oh man
here's what you are reminding me of tell
me if I'm off
I'm a full-time College administrator
um
the executive leadership team student
affairs division
and then I have a little boy and he
turns 18 months and I realize I don't
know how to do this because every time I
hold him he cries for Mom and I don't
know how to like I play trucks and then
I'm so bored within 38 seconds I want to
take the truck and stab it into my
eyeball and my wife has changed I've
changed I don't know what to do
but I'm good at my job
and so I start doubling down a little
bit more and a little bit more and then
I took on a full-time faculty role on
top of my full-time administrative role
and then I took another part-time job
out of the president's office working on
a special project
and all of that in my head was this idea
that I'm working towards This Magic
Moment that I'm Gonna Be Free
and I'm going to achieve my way towards
um I'm gonna over achieve at work to
make up for I don't really know what the
crap I'm doing in my house
foreign
or am I wrong
yeah I mean a lot of that rings with me
uh and and now I mean the end of this
the season now for us is
uh largely just sales
um the last round of birds are done the
bees are up for the winter obviously
produces done
um and uh I mean we just kind of barely
scratched I don't even know if we've
made it I mean it
he crawled across the Finish Line this
year just just barely hanging on and the
uh it you know I walked through the day
struggling in the day job thinking about
all the things I got and it just feels
like somebody's standing on me yeah and
I I don't know how
uh
I mean I just want to just kind of like
sit in my burning house and and you know
let it
fall in but hey at least it's warm yeah
exactly exactly like there's comfort in
the chaos I don't
because hey if when there's comfort in
the chaos you get to avoid reality
because when you're putting out fires or
you're dodging the smoke you actually
feel like you're accomplishing something
that you don't feel like when you're
just sitting by your wife holding her
hand
or that you're sitting down on all fours
rolling a ball back and forth with a
two-year-old that going
and then randomly just says I hate you
right
at least when the house is on fire you
got something to do
the problem is the house is on fire
yeah and I try to bring him with me
hey hey you're a good dad man
you're a good dad
it's just too much right now it's too
much
so my question for you would be is now
the time to have 22 000 million dozen
eggs
it is now this time to be like you know
what else we should do we should add
bees let's do bees and you know what I
know I know you've already thought about
bringing goats or sheep or cows on next
year
well if we find the property I knew it
see sucker listen you're gonna busy
yourself to death
yeah you talk about like diseases of
Despair and I feel the I think it's just
a lonely place and it almost feels like
the heart just like hey that that last
day was so busy you just took three of
three days away from me I mean it just
um
yeah yeah you know when's the last time
you took a break man
uh
uh oh let me ask you let me ask you a
different way how's your marriage
uh so yesterday was actually our
anniversary we uh quote unquote
celebrated with
carryout and hanging out not really
having really anything significant about
it
and I was even more bothersome
so when I ask you the question you did a
great job hanging in there with me you
did a great job evading it but when I
ask you how's your marriage the answer
the truthful answer is not well right
yeah or
not what you had envisioned it would be
yeah
um do you hate your engineering job
oh I hate it
okay I mean it's until it's the golden
handcuffs feeling yeah
I got that I've been there I've totally
been there I got it
I don't want to uh
uh it seems selfish if I if I were to
just say you know what throwing all my
cards in on this we've
we've uh you know proven we can make
some money if I put more time in it
we'll make some more money and
but if that were to fail I don't know if
I would it just feels incredibly selfish
in the shame that would follow that is
that I just can't even imagine here's
what's here's what's more shameful if
you ask me
there's no shame in making a calculated
risk and going for it
because if you take a calculated risk
not an idiotic risk not a moronic risk
but one with a spreadsheet and some
wisdom and some people who've done this
before and sit down and chart it out
with you
not one that's going to take on a whole
bunch of debt and it's going to put you
and your family the livelihood at risk
but a calculated risk that can pay off
significantly for your family is good
and a calculated risk that could pay off
that fails is extraordinarily good for
your kids because they get to watch
their dad got in a ring and took a swing
at the biggest guy in there and he got
knocked down and then they get to see
what happens when you get knocked down
and you get back up so that's not the
issue I think more shameful
is
living a life of quiet desperation and
teaching your son this is what manhood
is
I think more shameful is sacrificing
your marriage to the altar of busy
yeah right or trading Dragon feels like
it it does
I would rather and this is going to
sound crazy and here's how radical I'm
suggesting I'd rather see you sell the
farm tomorrow
to put up for sale
and spend three years in your
engineering job with a with an idea that
in 36 months I'm out of here I have no
debt I've put my family in a position
where we got six to nine months to a
year's salary so we can jump off this
thing and do something different
right now you're spreading yourself so
thin
or I'd rather you hire somebody to run
the farm for the next 24 months keep it
hire somebody so that you're not having
to work a full-time engineering job and
go out and do this and you're going to
lose money
but you're building right now
yeah and nobody you you your mind your
training you could create a plan
infinitely better than what I could draw
up with my Humanity psychology
background
I'd be wanting to think about everything
you know how to actually chart it out on
a piece of paper and say I'm gonna start
here and by this date I'm gonna have
this much money I'm gonna owe this many
people zero dollars
I'm gonna be ready to make a move then
and then you sit down with your wife and
say we have 24 more months
how can we carve out the greatest life
worth living in those 24 months while I
put extra work on top of extra work on
top of extra work into the still
because here's what I'm wondering I'm
wondering if you hate engineering it's
totally fair and you created an Exit
Plan
and you slowly started building your
exit strategy and now you're halfway in
it you don't like it either
oh uh I should mention I mean this is
year three okay so it's not like
yesterday or no no I know I know but is
it possible that you're year three and
you're like oh gosh this is a lot a lot
a lot a lot of work
oh I I I'm totally aware of the the work
you know I really do truly find a lot of
Joy when somebody comes back after they
buy
uh you know say uh chicken breast and
and throw them and say man those were
freaking awesome I don't know how you
raise those birds but it was fantastic
or the honey with this or that or the
other I mean it's just an awesome High
absolutely it really I do feel like I'm
really serving somebody the best way
that I know how I think my wife enjoys
you know that part of it as well she
certainly doesn't like to get her hands
dirty as much as I do but listen Hey
listen listen her eyes your whole voice
change is talking about this
it's quite yeah I mean your whole voice
changes
so let's do this almost spiritual to me
yes so let's do this let's stop screwing
around with the other stuff
you can't you can't keep no no no
with the
go into engineering every day and hating
it
farming all hours of the night not being
present with my wife not learning the
skills of how to be a husband to
somebody who's
um
got a kid not learning the new skills on
how to be a present father you may not
have got that from your old man
or you may have got a great old man but
just times have changed and you got to
learn some new skills
right now you're trying to do all these
things at the same time and it's not
going to work
so either come up with a scorched Earth
plan financially in your home we are
going to not spend a single penny beyond
what it takes to survive for the next
six months because I gotta get out of
this engineering job
and I'm going to go Full Tilt into this
farming deal if we can afford it we can
make it
and if we do the math and we realize we
can't make it we'd have to have another
billion eggs or another whatever
then we're gonna figure something else
out
and by the way the other night me and
Ben Hill and several others played in a
rock band it was so incredible so fun
there was thousand two thousand people
out there screaming yelling going
bananas
it was a spiritual moment for me
if you ask my 18 year old self it's what
I was put on Earth to do to be in a
metal band
and I also had to come to terms with it
doesn't pay my bills
and it breaks my heart and it makes me
sad because I would love to do that as
much as I love this job I would love to
be a full-time Rock and roller it's not
gonna happen
I'm not that good
and so instead of trying to do it for a
living I do it in pockets and I do it
regularly and I do it by myself
sometimes and I do it with a group
sometimes and if there's a big show I'll
throw my name in the ring
but I've turned it into a hobby instead
of a way of being right
but if nothing else you hear
this may not be the season four you fill
in the blank you're gonna have to take a
break from something
because this can't continue I can hear
it in your voice
last thing is
you need to go talk to a a grown man
ahead of you a couple of men who are
wise who've been who are 10 years ahead
of you on the farming game five years
ahead of you in the engineering game who
have had kids who are 10 years old and 8
years old who are ahead of you
because right now it feels like you're
drowning and you're probably not
drowning like you think you are but it
feels like it because all the feelings
are new
that's why Community is so important get
some men in your life who've got some
wisdom who are a little bit ahead of you
down the road okay hang on the line I'm
gonna send you a copy of on your past
change your future too and I want you to
read it and think about this other stuff
because there's you and I could talk for
a long time I know it
um I want you to get to the bottom of
the life you've you've accepted
and be about building something new